[Musique]
un enfant un animal pédiatre et
psychologues s'accordent plus en plus à
reconnaître l'importance du rôle de
l'animal sur le comportement de l'enfant
on trouve aujourd'hui dans beaucoup
d'écoles et dans certains établissements
hospitaliers des animaleries qui
permettent le contact permanent avec les
enfants
[Musique]
ce qui est important l'enfant a peur de
l'adulte est toujours jugée par l'adulte
or là il peut établir des relations
librement sans contrôle de l'adulte et
peut donc prendre un essor que la dupuis
refusent souvent
les enfants ont besoin de l'affection
d'un animal et ont besoin d'aller à la
conquête de l'animal vous avez vers
l'âge de tous 14 ans tout un autre au
symbolisme qui apparaît car l'enfant qui
veut devenir adulte s'identifient à
l'animal pour essayer de grandir et pour
développer son agressivité
nous sommes ici au refuge du château
gontier les enfants réunis en club en
prise en charge des animaux qui ont été
soit abandonnées par leurs propriétaires
soir pays malade où des six pour être
soigné depuis combien de temps viens tu
es très 3 7 et 3 ans c'est impossible
c'est pour ça qu'ils nous ont occupés
comme les animaux tient n'achète wade a
démontré qu est ce que le cas
aujourd'hui toujours j'ai un chien
pisteur tour est enfin bon moment je
vais à chypre a salué des chouettes
étaient des frères et soeurs qui a mieux
les animaux étaient travailleurs chinois
ah ouais ça n'existe pas si j'ai une
préférence comme sur les animaux fille
est le calque à l'animal va sortir un
jeu j'aime tous pareils mais ici ici
j'aime bien lire at on l'aidera temps la
betty et tué huit images et gilles
briant sur petit mot pour tes beaux lots
thibaut petit bobo pourquoi oui les
moins farouches qui le lie à présent et
tu viens ici l'été combien de temps ont
à peu près six mois six kouici six 6
mois
cette paix oui c'est ce que les bleus
auraient j'aime bien les animaux j'aime
bien leur caresser les allées voir les
j'aime bien animaux j'aime bien aussi
parce qu'il ya mise en jeu mais dit
sauter sauter je nettoie sa cage par oui
et quel autre animal ou encore j'aime
bien
j'aime bien me vous aussi qui le petit
renard blanc qui changent de couleur en
euros saisis à bord ils changent de
couleur pour massa enfin quand il fait
beau et c'est un renard polaire alors qu
en ce moment il est blanc et allaiter
votre grille un peu pas c'est pourquoi
il est blanc et un peu près de toi parce
qu'il doit faire froid
doit prendre un peu larges hublots ces
brèches par exemple je sais pas prêts
pour ça qu'au foot ou si c'est pour se
confondre dans la neige avant moi qui se
cache
il faut se cacher quand elle classe en
6e a depuis combien tu es un refuge
depuis dix ans et demi trois ans et
qu'est ce qui a poussé à venir parce que
ça me plaisait qu'est-ce qu'il dit là
bas c'est surtout les animaux qui ont un
travail
faux culs aps casio faible bon on
freudisme ans ont étoilé on et watson
les animaux et quel est l'animal et
c'est par ici
oh moi je les aime tous mais de
préférence avant bourse
c'est l'ours pourquoi parce que y
il est marrant quand il s'amuse du maroc
malgré les apparences les enfants savent
que sous ses aspects pato l'ours peut
être dangereux c'est pourquoi ils le
font entrer dans son enclos avant de
procéder au nettoyage de sa cage
[Musique]
je recherche à avoir caressé les moules
leur parler les nourrir je m'occupais
quoi est ce que tes parents sans grandes
banques qui viennent ici oui sont
chantés trouve que ça me c'est
intéressant
elles étaient des animaux chez toi non
bien pour ça que je viens ici même temps
[Musique]
j'y pense